Default function arguments in
JavaScript are here. This is one
of those features that's going
to make both your life much
easier, as well as make your
code much more readable and
maintainable. Let's say we have
a function called calculateBill
and that function is going to
take in three things -- the
total for our meal, how much we
spent on it, how much we need to
pay in taxes, the percentage,
and then how much you would like
to tip your waiter. From that,
we can return the total, the tax,
and the tip rate. If you think
I'm going to
you for not tipping on the tax
amount, get out of here. I don't
want to talk to you. Then we'll
make a new variable called
totalBill, and we'll use our new
function, maybe of a $100 meal,
the tax rate in Ontario here is
13 percent, and tip rate is
maybe 15 percent. We need to
figure out how much all of that
costs. That tells us 128 bucks.
What happens if we want to
assume 13 percent tax rate, and
we want to assume a 15 percent
tip rate? Previously, what we
would do, and maybe let's just
go ahead and take those things
off, we get an error here, NaN.
That's because we're trying to
do math against things that
aren't passed in. What is the
value of tax and tip when they
get passed in? They're going to
be undefined. Watch, cancel log,
tax, and it's going to tell us
that is undefined. What we
would normally do is we would go
into here, and we say, if tax is
undefined, then tax equals 013.
Then we would also do, if tip is
undefined, we would say tip is
equal to 015. Then it would
actually go ahead and work for
us. See, it works fine there,
but there's a whole lot of code
that we added. You might be
saying, "Yeah, you can do this,
tax equals tax," or you can do
this little trick here where you
can say it equals itself. If "
itself" is undefined, then the
13 percent will go in, but
that's OK. I don't mind that,
but it can be a little bit hard
on your team to have to read it,
and also if you've got four or
five different arguments coming
in, then you've got to do all
this crazy code at the top, so
let's just do without that
entirely. What we can do now in
ES6 is just simply set it when
we define our function. Let's
say tax equals 013 and tip
equals 015. Those things will be
assumed. If nothing is passed
in for that one, then the
defaults are going to go ahead.
There we go. Good. What else we
can do? What if I wanted to pass
only the total amount, as well
as the tip amount, because I'm a
big tipper. Let's say I'm
tipping 25 percent here. For tax
rate, that's not going to change,
because I'm still here in
Ontario. Can I just leave it
empty, like we've done here? No,
syntax error. It doesn't. How
do you leave a hole in here?
Well, what does this essentially
check for? It checks for someone
passing "undefined," so you can
just explicitly pass undefined.
What that does is it's going to
pass undefined as tax. The
function is going to say, "Oh,
no one passed any tax." It's
going to assume 013 and then the
customer tip is going to kick in
here. You see, I've got 138
bucks. That's it. Pretty simple.
I've got another one where this
is order dependent and when we
hit destructuring, I'm going to
show you how do you use an
object in destructuring here, so
that you could pass this in any
order, as well as have default
arguments. See you in that
video.